[Musique]
madame monsieur bonjour regardez cette
image c'est finalement celle de la
démocratie celle de la justice quarante
trois ans après son départ dans le
dernier train le 30 août 1940 classe
klaus barbie redevient l'homme que tous
les deux nés regarde
l'audience va commencer dans quelques
instants elle a pris évidemment un peu
de retard comme toutes les
manifestations de ce poids et de cette
importance
les photographes et les cameramen
agissent encore pour filmer les parties
civiles et l'arrivée de maître vergès le
défenseur de klaus barbie
il y a toute la presse mondiale réunis
dans cette salle pour juger un dossier
qui dépasse de loin le cadre générale
ordinaire de ce qui se jugent dans la
cour d'assises de lyon klaus barbie est
arrivé il ya quelques instants dans le
palais de justice de lyon son convoi
fortement escorté à traverser la ville
par un itinéraire qui a été choisi au
dernier moment
il est rentré dans le dépôt et il a été
aussitôt emmené dans la cellule de repos
que nous avons montré notre jour où son
avocat maître vergès c'est venu le voir
ainsi que le médecin du samu qui doit
tout au long du procès surveiller l'état
santé de l'accusé
dans quelques instants le prix dans
l'assise andré santini doit entrer par
cette porte que vous voyez au fond de
leur image
il sera accompagné de deux assesseurs
les conseillers de cours d'appel les
quais et pichery tu le président salini
va être accompagnée également de deux
magistrats suppléant supplémentaires qui
vont suivre les débats avec lui et qui
pourront remplacer les magistrats
titulaire si l'un d'eux à un malaise ou
un empêchement quelconque tout au long
de ce procès la salle des pas perdus du
palais de lyon a été aménagé pour qu'on
tire environ 7 à 800 personnes
je crois qu'il y en a beaucoup plus
maintenant déjà et cette salle a une
histoire finalement parce que depuis sa
construction le palais de lyon est
beaucoup trop petit il a été construit
en 1842 par lui baltard et dès la fin de
sa construction
on est obligé d'ajouter deux bâtiments
et de niveaux qui ont été achetés en
on doit depuis longtemps à lyon
construire une cité judiciaire
mais on l'attend encore voici maintenant
la sonnerie qui annonce l'arrivée de la
cour voici le président andré serghini
le président au cernil 58 ans président
de la cour d'assises du rhône depuis
trois ans
et rentrer avec lui l'avocat général
pierre truche 58 ans procureur général
de lyon également depuis trois ans qui
sera assisté par le substitut général
jean-olivier viout qui seront ces deux
derniers magistrats étant l'accusation
le voici leur avocat général pierre
truche
voici jean review l'audience est ouverte
je demande aux services d'ordre
d'introduire l'accusé s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
voici fossiles et de ses gardes klaus
barbie
il faisait régner la terreur aujourd'hui
la justice
plus demandés que vous pouvez vous
asseoir le seul accusé l'église celle du
code pénal d'avenir celle qui doit
messieurs la décennie 2000 et la défense
les avocats de la partie civile
des participants
image symbole joue également dans
quelques instants de cette loge grâce à
ses victimes admission est dans les
mains de paris les nouveaux interprètes
et faire bouillir ou 6 il est donc hors
prisons qui je ne fais pas
personnellement mais l'écho mais honni
villers d'échelle théoriquement leur
maître mais procter celle d'être présent
metal humains ont réalisé une jeune il
parle très bien le français mais comme
eux mais il veut sans doute heath en
unissant la diffusion ce serait le temps
de réfléchir sur les perses
le président s'est dit ni fait
actuellement l'appel est partie civile
monsieur portes voici l'ensemble des
abonnés est arrivé à l'ombre et leur
reconnaître des climats génère drapeau
bohème et trial uci
vous avez madame choix c'est minable
atteint voilà vous avez monsieur riley
nigériane m celle qui provient du qui va
les parties si l'un des avocats les plus
importants puisqu'il a mené à une masse
de documents à la cuisse de l'utj gare
fanny même l'aéro roland dumas il a
également maître henri noguères prison
la ligue des droits de l'homme
mahdia j'irai d'ailleurs ou non de cette
association
madame klaus barbie que vous voyez à
parer à une nouvelle génération
le symbole du nazisme c'est sans doute
un poids écrasant pour un homme de 74
ans jugé pour des actes commis alors
qu'il n'avait que 27 ans il était au
moment de sa présence à lyon louvre et
au symbole de la puissance et de
l'arbitraire protéger encouragé par ces
chefs qui ont été d'ailleurs jugé et
gracié qui sont aujourd'hui en liberté
aujourd'hui finalement klaus barbie est
seul il faut le reconnaître il portait
le numéro 2 139 dans la liste des
criminels de guerre
en réalité il ne reste plus en liberté
qu'un seul lunel nazis classé parmi les
premiers à louise bruner on sait où il
vit à damas en syrie
il semble y être en sécurité
klaus barbie apparaît en bonne santé ces
médecins qui vont des amines et
récemment l'ont confirmé au président
les assises
il s'intéresse visiblement al ahly à
l'énoncé de la liste des parties civiles
vous voyez peut-être l'un l'une des
interprètes lui annoncer et lui désigné
c'est l'avocat des avocats des
associations qui sont parties civiles
partie civile contre lui m
je m'entendais très bien précieux dont
il faut préciser je crois que si nous
voyons en ce moment klaus barbie c'est
parce qu'il a accepté d'être filmée par
les télévisions il avait le droit de
refuser absolument il avait le droit de
refuser il l'a fait d'ailleurs mais
l'interprétation juridique de la loi a
permis au président de passer outre pour
ce qui concerne l'enregistrement
historique aussi fonctionne
l'enregistrement date 8 et de leur
vision
l'orbit finalement s'est décidé à
accepter alors qu'au départ semble-t-il
il était plutôt opposés et pas nous
avons le droit de filmer comme on vend
ce moment les premières minutes de ce
procès mais c'est tout n'est ce pas oui
alors nous allons dans quelques instants
à la fin de l'énoncé des parties civiles
arrêter la transmission
parce que nous allons aborder l'un des
moments les plus sucrés en quelque sorte
de huis clos du procès c'est à dire la
désignation des jurés
le juré qui avec les trois magistrats je
romps constitue rend la cour d'assises
le président sani va très certainement
prendre cinq ou six jurés
supplémentaires pour pallier là aussi un
éventuel empêchement d'un juré alors six
jurés dont nous avons connaissance de la
liste originale sont des lyonnais bien
entendu moyenne d'âge 35 40 ans de
gueule de niveau socioprofessionnel
moyens surtout ce qui est important ce
qui sont très jeunes et une génération
finalement diyar l'a pas connu barbie
il a et noëlla pas connu barbie comme le
juge d'instruction christian riss
d'ailleurs qui au moment où il a reçu le
dossier n'avait que 37 ans les jurés
seront désignés et ensuite on passera à
l'appel des témoins les témoins dont
certains sont déjà là presque tous
d'ailleurs et qui vont après avoir
assuré de leur présence est reconduit
dans la salle des témoins ne pourront en
sortir qu au moment où le président a
dit ni leur demandera de revenir là
votre avis pas le combien de temps va
prendre la lecture par le greffier de
l'acte d'accusation quatre ou cinq
heures probablement vous savez que la
petite aviation ce sont ces la vie de
barbie c'est ce sont les faits qui lui
sont reprochés
et c'est également la liste des charges
qui pèsent sur lui
vous savez que klaus barbie est accusé
de plusieurs crimes contre l'humanité
qui peuvent se résumer en cinq grandes
lignes d'abord la rafle la déportation
des 50 enfants du home d'izieu c'était
d'en haut le 6 avril 44
et puis la liquidation en aussi de 9
février 43 du comité de l'union générale
des israélites de france c'est ce qu'on
appelle la rafle de la rue
sainte-catherine
ensuite le dernier train du bronze ou 44
650 personnes au moins 40 a perdu la
liste évidemment n'a pas été retrouvé
manière définitive le train du 11 44
tirs emmener tous ces gens dans les
camps de concentration alors que ben
arbia cela pouvait très bien les laisser
comme d'autres allemands l'ont fait dans
d'autres régions de france alain le poc
les alliés arrivé c'était plutôt
tellement nécessaire d'envoyer les gens
en concentration barbie a assisté et a
signé 7 sept emplois ensuite il y a deux
crimes contre l'humanité particulier
l'un intéressant le professeur marcel
gompel 10 est mort ensuite en
déportation mais qu'elle était
auparavant torturé par barbie rentrant
ensuite la déportation et la mort de
georges le sev de son fils elle met sa
femme également lisent le serbe a été
déporté mais elle est revenue elle est
dans la salle et son témoignage sera sa
team hm très lourd d'ailleurs on peut
penser que
en dehors des 4,5 pièces du vernis sont
des documents et dise ce buzz rond lourd
sur la conviction des jurés
ce qui va à sa demande en importer le
plus ce sera la longue déposition de 7,6
de témoins qui viendront raconter
viendront raconter ce qui s'est passé et
je pense que c'est témoignage aura un
symbole particulier parce que ces gens
ont souvent dit que leurs camarades qui
mouraient à leurs côtés dans les camps
de concentration leur disait vivait pour
raconter et sans ces gens viennent
aujourd'hui témoigner c'est peut-être là
peu plus important de leur vie ma classe
et de témoigner de la souffrance et de
la mort de leur mari
il faut rappeler paul que ces crimes
contre l'humanité sont imprescriptibles
à la différence bien sûr des crimes de
guerre oui les crimes de guerre sont
prescriptibles à partir de 10 ans au
delà de 10 ans pardon tandis que les
crimes contre l'humanité sont
imprescriptibles en fonction de la
définition du tribunal de nuremberg du 8
août 1945
d'ailleurs c'était 7 imprescriptibilité
ce mois ci la dir est et introduire
connu dans le droit français par une loi
du 16 septembre 64 adoptée par
l'ensemble du parlement bien entendu et
alors la cour de cassation le juge
d'instruction avait d'abord en
appliquant le strict droit français
écarté du dossier un certain nombre de
plaintes
parce qu'ils considéraient qu'il venait
de résistants de gens arrêtaient comme
résistant et ensuite déporté la suite
d'appels successifs la cour de son da
cour de cassation la chambre criminelle
a donné le 20 décembre 85 une nouvelle
des villes du crime contre l'humanité
qui va d'ailleurs être inscrit dans les
textes internationaux et on peut
résilier ses suspensions en disant que
son crime contre l'humanité les actes
inhumains commis au nom d'une hégémonie
idéologique pour persécuter pour des
motifs raciaux et religieux réduction en
esclavage déportation en sommes à partir
de là les juges français ont tous
considéré que le fait même d'envoyer
quelqu'un en déportation de le réduit à
la mort par la faim ouvre un travail
fatigant et est un crime contre
l'humanité et c'est ainsi que plusieurs
personnes qui avaient été écartés par le
juge christian risques conformité avec
l'ancienne définition de la loi ont pu
rentrer dans le dossier ont dit pour se
retrouver aujourd'hui étaient brouillées
entre lui est ce que vous savez quand
vont commencer les plaidoiries des
avocats car l'affrontement pas fan oms
très rude entre maître vergès l'avocat
de barbie et puis m e klarsfeld l'un des
avocats des parties civiles bien brut
patricia pendant que le président
continue la lecture des parties civiles
je vous donnais un petit peu le
programme effet répondent ainsi à votre
région
après la désignation du jury aujourd'hui
lit ensuite l'appel des témoins nous
allons commencer cet après-midi à
entendre la lecture de l'acte
d'accusation par le greffier monsieur de
sage de gages qui est un petit peu au
dessus de barbie à gauche et alors le la
création est prévue pour environ 5 à 6
heures c'est un accueil euphorique
[Musique]
voir et pendant qu débat est ensuite
l'acte d'accusation de nous aurons là le
récit de la vie de barbie mais pas les
faits ensuite dans deux jours
probablement les psychiatres de
psychiatres psychologues qui ont été
examinés barbie et qui viendront nous
dire quelles sont ces structures
psychologiques et psychiques
je pense que nous commençons à étudier
l'effet qu'a l'inde ou qu'au début
peut-être à la fin de cette semaine au
début de la semaine prochaine
en réalité l'affrontement va commencer
au moment de l'interrogatoire sur les
faits qui commencera probablement mais
au début de la semaine prochaine et
cette interrogatoire sera certainement
le signal de l'affrontement entre
défense et partie civile c'est à dire
que maître vergès a d ores et déjà à
boire à réfuter ou a révélé en quelque
sorte sa stratégie de défense
ensuite le long défilé des témoins sans
doute des semaines et des semaines nous
et y avait un sens un témoin et des gens
que l'on ne peut pas interrompre parce
que le jeu vous lisez tout à l'heure on
sent vraiment des choses à dire je pense
que les plaidoiries ne commenceront
qu'au début du mois de juillet
une question pomme sur les magistrats y
savent bien sûr que ce procès est
historique puisqu'il est sans doute l'un
des derniers de la guerre dont les
témoins soient survivants comment l'ont
ils préparés et bien d'abord comme je
voulais dit tout à l'heure le juge
christian riss qui a reçu le dossier le
12 février 82 qui est maintenant
substitut résulte il ya deux ans on
avait 35 ans à l'époque c'est lui qui a
instruit ce dossier historique dans des
conditions très difficiles
l'accusation était donc représenté par
le parquet général de lyon monsieur
pierre truche ci a considérablement aidé
avec son substitut monsieur view dia
considérablement aider le juge crise
dans la recherche de la vérité et
surtout dans la recherche des documents
monde cherche cartel a beaucoup
retrouver de documents je peux dire que
l'essentiel des documents qui sont
actuellement dans le dossier ont été
retrouvés par serge klarsfeld
il a évidemment automatiquement
communiquées au parquet général et au
juge d'instruction
lorsque le juge d'instruction a eu
terminé son enquête il a clos le dossier
il l'a confié au parquet général de lyon
et la chambre d'accusation de lyon a
réexaminé pour se voir si le dossier est
complet lac au bout c'est la longue
procédure dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure c'est à dire dès la définition
des crimes de guerre et crimes contre
l'humanité
ça a duré de longs - parce que le
dossier partie des cours d'appel de lyon
il est remonté à l'achat
criminelle de la cour de cassation qui a
confié le supplément d enquête à la cour
d'appel de paris a quant à elle de paris
a bouclé on dit ficelé en termes
juridiques ans plus tôt en terme de
jargon juridique qui a fuit scène au
ciel abandonnant leur envoyer devant la
cour d'assises du rhône et pour jugement
sinon est-ce que la durée de 4 ans qui a
été nécessaire pour cette instruction
depuis l'arrivée de bach mai à la prison
de lyon vous semble à un temps normal
pour cette instruction
oh je pense même que c'est un temps
relativement court lorsqu'on examine
l'ensemble des procédures criminelles en
france l'instruction de ces procès au
criminel
je pense que dans un dossier pareil
d'une telle complexité qui nécessitait
des recherches un peu partout dans le
monde je crois que ça a été relativement
vie l'association du
klaus barbie est actuellement voyez en
train d'observer les parties civiles
sont face à lui il est installé
il est installé temps
dans un box le box des accusés on le
voit mal mais il ya une sorte de vitres
qui est à l'épreuve des balles
il le protège en quelque sorte d'une
agression donc à côté de lui les deux
interprètes qui vont se relayer en
dessous son avocat maître vergès et sa
collaboratrice
c'est un long chemin que cet homme à
parcourir avant d'arriver il est certain
que sinon la fin de sa vie c'est
probablement la fin de son aventure et
on n'en sait pas très bien quelle
stratégie personnelle il y va il aura au
cours de ce procès m'a t-il suivre
complètement la tactique de maître
vergès son avocat où va-t-il révélé
entre guillemets un certain nombre de
choses c'est à dire quoi les liens
qu'ils pourraient avoir eu avec un stand
de lyonnais où les révélations qu'il
pourrait faire sur des mystères de la
collaboration assez joué l'entente le
président sur 10 ni demande maintenant à
la presse de résistance écarté en
respect de la loi
car nous allons arriver que vous êtes
tout à l'heure à la désignation des
jurés qui sont lui d'apparaître pro tour
là par exemple à cesser cet
enregistrement je vous le rappelle est
le premier de l'histoire judiciaire
française
il a eu une incidence de films quand été
pris par exemple au moment du procès
pétain et du procès la balle aussi
c'étaient des films qui ne pourraient
pas lente l'entière durée du procès avec
l'anrs pour l'historique dans les câbles
arabe on restait en fonctionnement et
qui vont tourner continuellement sous la
surveillance d'un magistrat dit va
tenter de rester respecter l'objectif
acté la mesure des images les cassettes
seront remises
tous les soirs prestance d'assises qui
les confiera aux archives de france
on pourra les consulter au bout de 20
ans et les utiliser au bout de 30 ans
[Musique]
voici patricia